إنه أمر ملهم للغاية مع أنك
تعرف الأطفال والشباب الذين أصبحوا
متحمسين للغاية عندما نوقع عليهم لأول مرة
، أشعر
بالفرح الشديد ، لقد لمست قلبي فقط ،
هؤلاء الأطفال يعانون من الحرمان اللغوي
، ولديهم عدد محدود من الأشياء الخاصة بالأطفال
وتركوا في محادثات مائدة العشاء
الأحداث العائلية هناك اتصال كامل
للحاجز ، ولكي يقوم Deaf
Santa بإجراء هذا الاتصال مع كل طفل
تعرفه ، هناك فهم ثقافي
لتجربة حياتنا
يساعد الآباء على معرفة ما إذا كان
أطفالهم سعداء ،
فأنا لم أر نفسي أبدًا أصبح سانتا
سألني أحدهم لأنه  من
لحيتي ولم أشعر أنه لم يكن
حقًا بالنسبة لي
ولكن زوجتي شجعتني على تقديم
الشكر لذلك حاولت
ارتداء الزي لأول مرة
وبدلة بابا نويل وشعرت حقًا بالسحر
الذي أريده  فخور بذلك ، فأنا
أعلم أنهم سمعوا بابا نويل لكنهم
لا يفهمون حقًا ثقافة الصم
أو تجربة الموت ، أي سانتا السمع
الذي يمكنه التوقيع على هذا رائع  إنه أمر
مثير ولكن من الجيد أن نشعر كما لو كان
بإمكانهم التواصل مع شخص مثلهم حقًا ،
فهذا فرق كبير